thank you for joining me today on this
webinar about avatars and finding
a sense of self and others in the
virtual worlds
with the arrival of virtual reality
we're seeing a change in paradigm on how
we interact with computers
we are no longer just seeing the content
inside the screen no matter how many
devices you have around
currently we see the content on inside
the screen
but we're moving the user inside the
content we might have
even less devices than we have now uh
but that completely changes how we
interact and one of the big changes that
happened
is that from that time on if you're
using virtual reality
you're not going to be able to see your
own body your body is occlude
of course this is different in augmented
reality where you can still see through
but in virtual reality this is a big
issue
and but it brings also a very
interesting question is can we
substitute
your body with an avatar in order to do
that
there are ways we can do it but you
enter into this
space of delusions on the perceptual
system in which humans
start perceiving things in different
ways and we need to understand really
well how humans perceive their body in
first place in order to be able to
substitute it correctly
so one of the earliest experiments
on on body ownership was the rubber
honey illusion but
both winning and coin relatively uh new
in
1998. let's see how that illusion played
so a participant would put their hand on
a glove
and leave their hand behind the curtain
so in front of their eyes they could
only see a rubber hand
so this rubber hand it's going to be
stimulated with bison tactile
stimulation
that is synchronous in in the two hands
in the
in the rubber hand and in the real hand
so they're gonna be seeing the same
thing that they are
feeling the same touch and after a very
brief exposure and
touch experience um they they have the
shift of body ownership towards the
rubber hand
and you can measure that for example by
producing harm
to the rubber hand and seeing how the
person actually reacts on the real hand
the truth is that in order to produce
this type of illusions that seem very
simple
we need to have an understanding of how
the brain works and the brain is a very
complex system right
it is very dynamic it will receive the
information over time
it will have prior understandings of how
we understand our body and the world
it will have ways to correct errors
and to convert stimuli of different
input for example
in the rubber honey illusion we were
seeing tactile and visual stimuli at the
same time
so despite the complexity we've seen on
the brain is
is quite easy to trick the brain for
example here we have two lines
that are exactly the same size a and b
but we see them very different right a
seems
smaller than b so
and and we need to to also see a little
bit the big picture on perception
and why is this complexity where is it
coming from and
and we can have a very evolutionary
perspective to it an anthropological
perspective to it even
which is this idea that animals start to
be very divergent the moment they start
perceiving
so um praise can perceive their
predators and predators can perceive
their praise so they have this
need for evolution and evolution and
perception
so there are many things we can learn
from there and transfer to virtual
reality
and and in particular what we see from
these very evolved sensory systems
is that there will be uh some sensors
that will be dominant
uh like in humans the visual system
we're very visual
animals so
and also on top of that we can develop
expertise right
and sensory expertise is something that
allows this ballerina
to know with their eyes closed where
every part of their body
is located through proprioception
and this integration this all these
sensors come together
and then you establish multi-sensory
integration which is this idea that
uh you you will have a stronger feelings
when more than one sensor agree
and stronger responses so i if you look
at the vagisian
theory of how this probability could
work
of you perceiving something
here for example we have two modalities
to
two modalities like in the rubber hand
illusion was the vision and the touch
that come together into the
multi-sensory neurons
and then the fact that the two of them
are telling you the same thing
will make you react much stronger like
if you're only perceiving touch or only
perceiving
the visual it will be much lower than if
you're perceiving both inputs
in virtual reality that happens all the
time
uh but in reality too and and we have
seen
even stronger things that just like the
combination of the two right like for
example on electrophysiology on animals
uh we've seen a cat will respond with a
particular voltage in the brain
when they hear a dog or when they see a
dog but
it's much more stronger when they hear
and see the dog and this is not just an
addition of the two
inputs or their independent type of
voltages it's a super addition
so it's a hundred fifty percent more
brain activation
when the the cat is seen and and hearing
the dog than in any other condition
and as i say in virtual reality this
happens all the time because in virtual
reality
we're having the vision input we're
having the the movement the
proprioceptive input
and and those are aligning together and
many times also we are even having the
haptic input
which is also aligning so we
we use this multi-sensory integration
and we can create body
illusions also on avatar so not just on
the rubber hand illusion
and we can use visio tactile integration
like on the rubber hand illusion or
visual motor integration which is more
natural in vr like moving around or like
just moving your head and the fact that
the visual
stimuli stimulus being updated
so one of the things that happened the
moment you substitute the body
with a vertical body is the embodiment
illusion
this idea that we start having direct
control of the avatar and
and we experience that like the avatar
is our own so here we see a person
who has her the whole body tracked
and they are inside the virtual
environment as
they move around they can see how their
body is now
changed for a virtual avatar
these will have implications because
they will change
probably their behavior in different
ways we will explore a bit of that now
and and we are trying to explore also
and
understand the mechanisms and um and the
systems that underlies all these effects
of embodiment so one of the
very interesting things about the
embodiment is that we can embody
avatars of different shapes sizes
genders
and races and and um
even things like being a giant are
at our hand right like here
you're walking over a very small city
and having this experience
of very very different size
you can even embody a robot
so here you have a person who is
embodied in
in a robot and moving their hand and
interacting with another person
and and there are very interesting
things we need to understand that happen
when you are embodied in an avatar and
one of them is this idea of this
self-avatar follower effect uh the
moment you enter a virtual reality
environment and there is an avatar in
front of you like in here with the hand
on top of the table
participants will just simply enter and
put their hand on the table because
there is this
need to fill the gap between the
physical and the self-avatar bodies
and and this type of compensations we
have explore
uh produce this self-avatar follower
effect
uh here we can see how what happens even
if we drift the avatar right like it's
not just a static
so we ask this person to perform a task
to move
the hand forward always forward and then
we move the avatar as they are doing
that
so we can see that as we move down the
avatar the person starts moving down to
despite we're asking them to just
continue doing this
specific task so the users try to
compensate to always feed with their
avatar
we want to understand a bit more about
this embodiment illusion especially this
this something that you know
it's very interesting to to put in
different categories
what what are the components of
embodiment right and
and there are these three main
components one is this body ownership
the fact that this is my body
uh the other is the self-location of the
body and this is interesting because
sometimes we're playing in third person
perspective or like the body seems in
front of us
and it's still our body and we have this
experience like we're
seeing it from behind and you know it's
kind of
doesn't need to be a self location
attached
and the third one is this idea of agency
that
i am in control of the emotions and the
movements and i am the person who is
creating those movements on the avatar
and when you have a good coordination of
these three components
you can create very substantially this
embodiment illusion
so one of the things that i first
explored was how can we create
better and more strong embodiment or
ownership illusions in general
and uh mirrors was very clear
a very good tool and we don't need
mirrors in real life because we have
this very
large field of view where we can see
our body even from the periphery and
that is not currently true in most
virtual reality headsets because they
don't have that super large field of
view yet
so the the other option you have is to
perform tasks that are always in front
of you so you're gonna
make people look at their avatar as
they're moving
um one thing that was always very
interesting to me
is okay yeah people answer to these
questioners
and they say they feel very embodied or
less embodied
but um it seems like you could be
cheating right like it's just a
questionnaire so i
i went very deep into doing
electrophysiological recording on humans
and i started measuring brain signals
and and seeing okay what if
you put your hand on the table and then
there is a knife that attacks you
and does it produce some sort of
brain signal different than if the knife
doesn't attack you similar to when the
rubber hand illusion is attacked
and yes what i find is there is a
substantial readiness potential
it's a preparation of uh between the
two hemispheres uh it is subconscious
it's an activation preparation for
movement
and then i also find a mule rhythm the
synchronizations on the on
on the also on the motor cortex
which also only happens when you are
attacking the hand and not the table
then i moved into exploring a bit more
the sense of agency
how does it work when you're asking
people to perform a motor task
when does it break and
so i asked people to perform this
eriksen flanker task in which
they have to follow this arrow in the
middle
um and it's a rapid decision-making task
and people will make mistakes but in
some cases we will also introduce
mistakes from the system right like you
move in one direction but you see
something different done by the avatar
so here let's watch
the actual experiment the person is
embodied onto this avatar
and then they start the task
a repetition of many many arrows they
have to move in the direction of the
arrow
and once every 21 trials
they will have an incongruent trial in
which they will move in one direction
but the avatar
will go in the other direction like just
now
so uh what happens there is it is your
movement because it's your speed
everything we just do a symmetric a
transfer of whatever you're doing and
and
it matches very nicely all these error
monitoring models and motor control
models from gallagher and fritz
so um to go very very
quickly and give an overview of what's
happening here right when you are
performing a motor control action
you have an intended state like i want
to have my hand here
on the left and then you create this
motor command in your brain
and execute the movement but the brain
keeps a copy of that
motor command which is a reference copy
and when the
afferent feedback you know your vision
comes back
and says oh this is actually the output
you have
is your hand is here but it doesn't
match the idea that you thought your
hand was in the other place
you create this very strong semantic
violation which is an m400
error in in the parietal cortex
of course you also have errors which are
related with you committing the mistake
because it's a
rapid decision task so you were supposed
to go in this direction you go in the
other
it's an error related negativity and i
think the most interesting thing
about this whole experiment is actually
uh
that we find a very good correlation
of um the electrophysiology
and the questionnaires and and that
happened also with all my other
electrophysiological experiments is that
very strong effects
correlate very much with what people
responded on the questionnaire
like how much embodied they were so then
i shift my focus because of course
people cannot do electrophysiology for
every experiment they do
and i thought okay what we really need
now is a standard questionnaire that
everybody uses
so i joined with professor david peck
from davidson college
into creating this a thorough
questionnaire
we analyzed 30 famous experiments
ever since the rubber hand illusion and
we
came out with these 25 questions
and more recently uh after doing 400
questioners right like 400 experiments
to people that we've done over the last
two years
we have been able to reanalyze the
answers and say
look this question really doesn't make
sense people don't understand it or like
there
it doesn't have dynamic range or like
doesn't describe
embodiment really well so we've been
able to reduce to 16 questions and
reduce also
to have a much simpler equation to to
calculate embodiment
uh in a standard way and this is
important
because embodiment changes across
participants and that's why we really
need to measure
embodiment for every time we use avatars
for
self-representation in virtual reality
there are cases in which you might have
people inside the same
exactly the same virtual experience and
they will have very different
performances and many times that is
because they were differently embodied
to their avatars
and not having an avatar it's also not a
solution
and i'll tell you why because there are
effects like distance compression that
happen in virtual reality which
uh if you ask a person to walk towards a
door they always
undershoot uh even by at 20
so they stop two meters before
and that doesn't happen when you are
well embodied onto an avatar like
we show here um so
here what we show is that very high
embodied participants
were less prone to distant compression
and it's not surprising in a way because
we perceive the world very much
by our own body like i know how
big this glass is by comparison to my
hand
and our body serves us metric very much
around everything we do
so it is not surprising that in virtual
reality it becomes also so critical and
all these cognitive tasks will require
also having a virtual body that
is is well matching even some
experiments have been done that
if you're embodied in a child you'll
have changes on
size perception and and so i think
this is also an area that shows how
important the embodiment
is and and to measure it on a
standardized way
another example of how embodiment is
important for perception
is for example in haptic perception
perception of touch
in here we ask people to tell us where
they perceive
something touch this dowel in in front
of them
and if they don't have a vertical body
they don't have this very strong
perception
and even if in the control condition
they could actually see
their controllers on the dole so they
have a point of reference but they
it's not the same as having their hands
because you know the controller
you know could have you don't have the
internal reference of the size so
so well uh integrated
another area that i've been very
interested on avatars which
it's important and many people ask is
uh what about the face right does it
need to be
looking like me a look-alike avatar or
uh all the areas around animation of the
face
so the to the first question of of uh
look-alike avatars
i explore further on this idea of
electrophysiology and there is this
very interesting effect on the visual
cortex
and uh in which you have a p200 with
lower voltage
when it is a an image of yourself and a
significant effect is also found on
virtual faces
it's not that strong again it's a
well described by subconscious and
subjective
uh interaction so people who really
think the avatar looked like them
were more likely to have a bigger
difference in in the voltage between
their avatar and the other phases
so also again over time what we find is
that
this difference between the burton and
the real was reduced so the more times
you spend with this virtual
yourself the more you're gonna strive
feeling like
it is yourself and self-recognizing
but uh recently i went on a spatial and
i thought oh you know
it doesn't look perfectly like me but it
it works really nice
and and it has these animations very
subtle that
that work very nice so uh we started
working a bit more
on this idea of animation because you
cannot always create an avatar that
looks like you
but you can always animate an avatar
and here on the left we have an avatar
that is not animated at all and it seems
like it's
even a bit dead and on the right we have
this saboteur that has
simple blinking minimal circades
very minimal expressions but it's
actually so much better than the other
ones so we
asked two people to uh multiple people
to look at them at the mirror with these
avatars and then
we put them on this morphing task in
which you see their faces are morphing
from themselves to the avatars
and they need to stop it whenever they
feel it doesn't look like them anymore
or in the other direction when it starts
to look like them
so what happens here is that people will
stop at different times of course and
this is a well-known effect that is
called
steresis uh it happens also in material
science when
you know uh water changes from ice to
water
or water to ice it will be at different
points in temperature
so here is very similar but it's
self-recognition
so you'll have different times at which
people
stop and think it's no longer me the
closer those points are
the more blended you have your
recognition
right like you are not so able to tell
it's not you anymore
and what we find is that the moment we
add animation and lip sync
very very minimal animation because it's
not even
representing your actual animation it's
more like an idling
that the face look alive uh we have a
significant reduction on these terraces
not only that we also see that people
look much more at the face
than in the other conditions so what's
interesting here is
uh we don't think that you look more on
the face than normally
what we think is that if the face is not
animated you don't you try to avoid
looking at the face
so it's more like a reduction on your
actual normal embracement or like your
normal interaction with
faces that you're trying to avoid the
face if it's not animated
so all of this shows you know that
you're actually changing your behavior
uh when you're interacting with avatars
depending on whether they're animated
whether
they're not and in fact perception
changes our behavior
all across our reality right the way we
perceive things we
will change how we behave around them
and in virtual reality this is true and
also
virtual reality has very particular
effect on creating realistic behaviors
that we don't see in other mediums
and it's because we have this strong
presence illusion
when you are interviewing a reality
you you experience this idea that you're
somewhere else and that the things that
are happening
are realistic responsibility illusion
and display solution
and there is this famous experiment from
you know it was presented at seagraph
but also
some years before to um which
ask people to cross a pit
a virtual pit uh in front of them
and and go to sit on a chair at the
other end
the moment people approach to the cliff
well first of all
nobody crossed the cliff to to reach the
other end everybody went through the
edge
uh but second the moment they approached
their heart rate went high and you know
there were all these physiological
responses to this
that despite everyone knew that this was
virtual right that this was not a real
setup so when we this is very important
when we go to avatars because this
realistic behavior
in virtual environments transfers to
realistic behavior with
other avatars so until now we've talked
very much about embodiment and
substituting our body
but what happens when we interact with
other avatars
um so we we reproduce an experiment
uh from milgram uh the milgram
experiments on obedience of
to authority in which he asked
people to electroshock another person
and
of course this is nowadays is ban you
cannot get
an ethical committee to agree on you
asking people to electroshock other
people
but in virtual reality you can do that
right because there is no deception
there everybody knows this is an avatar
and that you're
never going to be electrocuting for real
and avatar
but because of the realistic behavior
you can find that people respond very
similarly
and in fact we found that the responses
the number of people who drop
who continued the experiment were very
similar than
those in the original milgram experiment
so i'll go a bit more into the
experiment but
i uh we built this we brought this
general
public piece also on it and one of the
things we found is that people tried to
help the avatar
despite they were trying to of course
complete the task at the same
time so let's see how this look like
so here we have a participant who
is coming to the virtual reality this is
a cave it's not a
headset so they are interacting
with this a virtual avatar in front of
them which was our actor we recorded
it took six months to prepare this
experiment
so the person reads aloud a series of
words and the avatar is supposed to tell
you which one is the correct one the
correct match to the first one
so one of the things that happens there
is that
uh every time there is an incorrect
answer this person is asked to
electroshock
and there will be moments in which there
is a lot of tension
like uh here right in which
the avatar will try to
stop the experiment magic
so these these were parts that were
extracted from original scripts of the
milgram experiments and they are
in yale university for uh consultation
uh many many notes
and so we were very strict at following
what happened in the real experiments
and and transferring that to to the
avatar and this
interaction but i think the
the interesting thing here is that we
can use avatars to reproduce
uh experiences and and experiments
that are not possible outside virtual
reality like imagine you wanna
create a bar fight and and and see how
people interact
and how people will react by standard
effects what if there are ten other
people in the bar
what if you're alone what if uh this
person wears your
favorite soccer or football team jersey
what if you know all these in-group
out-group effects so all of that is
impossible in reality as an experimenter
you cannot go into a bar
and start a bar fight but you can have
this sort of experiences inside virtual
reality
and see how people will react uh and all
of that
you know it's it's hard to create
because you need to have avatars that
are animated
trigger them and and one thing i realize
is that if it took me six months on the
computer science department
to create this i mean a regular person
has no chance
so for me and and despite everything i i
you know one thing that i've learned is
that avatars are more important than
ever for virtual reality and
and for many experiences that we're
going to create and
actually if you want to read more about
this this piece
uh i think it it was very good at
explaining all of that i joined emily
uh on creating this piece um
for you know to pursue a bit more that
that
idea that more people need to be working
on avatars but still it's
it's very hard so i've moved into this
mode now in which i'm very heavily
invested
in democratizing and creating authoring
tools for other
other people to to be able to work more
with avatars and part of that effort
is being the release of the rocket box
avatars by uh
microsoft research and you can find it
in github here
um and we have recently
published this paper uh in frontiers in
vr where
you can find everything about avatars
across my talk you you have every single
experiment cited this way so these
avatars are over 100 avatars they're
rigged avatars so you can put animation
on them
with bones with different lods for
you know different qualities
and a standardized skeleton so if you
have an animation you can transfer it
from one avatar to another one
it's very easy to interact with them and
they are
free for academic use and and research
and now we're also releasing them as an
mit license so you can use them for
whatever you want
and this is great right and i have a
bunch of people in computer science like
stanford vr cornell vr ucl oxford
using this library is already this
avatar but i still feel like
there is a need for easier tools if i
want
a sociologist or other psychologist
to to work with these tools and and
therefore i've been looking for the last
summer very strongly
on creating a toolbox that will allow
for people to create
better motion capture and easier
embodiment and
you know reuse of archival footage to
recreate the scenes so
i'm going to go a bit of an an overview
of of what this new toolbox that we're
also releasing now
is uh working on realistic avatars are
an essential component for creating
social interactions
in virtual reality however the main
issue faced by small labs
is a lack of simple self-creation
animation tools in this paper
we present move box a plug-and-play
toolbox that aims to provide resources
for motion capture and animation of the
microsoft rocketbox avatars
without the need for professional
equipment
so the same thing that you know took me
so long
in ucl uh here i was
able to record all of these in in 15
minutes
reuse an audio that we had from another
collaborator
put it in and have this lip sync
experience and it was very simple to
create this animation and
partially i want to explain how the move
box works
uh it's based on three different
projects one is this
capture studio that uses a um
azure kinect or even connect version 2
to have the skeletal tracking and create
this full body animation
then you have this audio component that
can be real-time or pre-recorded
and use it for for lip sync and blinks
and then you have another a project
that will allow you to have motion
tracking and
and finger animation
let's go see a little bit more of how
this works
so here where uh there is a person
performing a motion
it's being recorded and then you can
replay it
uh this is the the lip sync tool of
course it's not a perfect lip sync it
doesn't have
a vowels or so on it's just a simple
open and close with the frequency and
volume and this is the finger tracking
so uh finger tracking and and body
tracking can be done with
a marty k or oculus quest and it is also
a specific project is it's uh set up for
you know putting the headset and having
the body man
situation with the inverse kinematics
for for the elbows
so that provides already very uh good
starting point for anyone who wants to
do embodiment a very good starting point
for anyone's to do
how do you would how would you react to
an avatar doing this
or a person doing this right with the
studio and then finally we have
another part of the
a second project that reduces
it's able to extract from archival
footage
using the vive which is an open source
tool
and put it inside the the
rocket box avatars so here you have
a video that is a pre-recorded
you didn't even have vr before that
right like it's
ten years ago and you're able to to
reconstruct
uh the whole motions and then transfer
them to
to this set of rocket box avatars so
this opens a whole new avenue right like
if you can use archival recording form
um from calls to the police or body cam
uh videos and then you can have a very
easy
re-implementation of what happened in
that scene and then propose it
uh to see how people would react to it
like i i can see many interesting
experiments with these type of tools
and you can also just do much simpler
you know whatever you want to do
it has a quite a quality right like you
can jump you can dance
uh you can record yourself in a stadium
with thousands other people and just
dance there with them
right um anything you want to do it can
be done and
it's everything we show in this video
it's been done with the move box so
you can download it and it it's going to
be presented in
aivr this year and i think this
kind of summarizes the work that i've
been trying to do to
have more people join me into
using more avatars in vr for their
experiments
and and for in general i think avatars
are very important
inside vr so
of course i don't do this work on my own
completely i have many
collaborators some at microsoft research
some are visiting researchers
interns external collaborators with whom
i work
a lot and i have a lot of fun and also
if you are
you know i'm still working on on new
releases of toolkits
uh maybe for facial animation maybe you
know and and
if you want to collaborate on those
please reach out
i'm very happy to collaborate always and
this is the end of my talk please stay
tuned
i'm happy to answer to your questions
now
hi everyone thanks for attending the
webinar on avatars today
and we're live on q a i'm mark gonzalez
and i will
over the next 50 minutes uh answer
questions that the audience has been
posting and you can still post some more
i flagged some of the questions already
and we can go through them
so let me go a little bit here
to the bottom so we had one question
about
um tactile perception and as i said
before right there is a lot of
perception changes how we behave because
how we perceive the world will change
how
we behave on the world and i i've done a
lot of work on perception too
and i think the release of the avatars
it's going to many areas of research
that have to do from social psychology
to a perception experiments perception
of their own body there are many things
we don't know about how we perceive the
body despite
you know few few findings uh seem to
suggest there is
a lot of diversity between participants
and there is also
um a lot of flexibility on how we
perceive the body
so there was a question about bishop
tactile
[Applause]
being stronger in the use than visual
motor
and what happens if this tactile
feedback is not synchronized perfectly
so one of the things there is
this one motor is super strong it's even
stronger than bison tactile because it's
it's a both a similar stimulation that
you produce
right uh versus tactile is generally
something you perceive that someone else
has produced so it doesn't have this
afferent effort and a connection uh
but i i wanted to to highlight this part
because there is a very interesting
experiment uh
that could be done very easily uh about
an avatar coming towards you and
touching on your back and you're turning
around and
and that is a a very causal inference
of of the stimuli in which you turn
around and there is an avatar and it
looks
fantastic and you could do the same
experiment
touching but there is no avatar so this
idea that tactile feedback needs to have
causality and be synchronized is very
important otherwise you break the
illusions and we
we explore this on the uncanny valley of
haptics
which is a paper we publish in science
robotics and i really
recommend people to check on it and i
think there's so much that can be
explored around this idea
and that i wanted to highlight this
then we had another question about
interception
and how it plays with breaking br body
illusions
i think interception which is the
perception of our own body signals
uh things like heart rate or or
heartburn
um you know when we see experiments like
uh that produce a lot of arousal and
there is questionnaires about your
own body perception right like do you
feel nervous do you feel nauseated these
type of things
um are very important to see how you're
triggering emotions on people
but i i kind of really like one area of
interception which is this
type of psychological mirror that
happens when you have two people
and i think avatars will be good enough
when you hear you see an avatar yawning
and that creates a yawning into you
right like this
this super typical emotional contagion
uh that is described in psychology and
happens in humans
and i haven't seen an avatar yet that
made me young
despite dogs can make you yawned right
so i think
uh interception can be a great tool to
explore further
as we move into better quality of
avatars
so uh there were some other questions on
ethical uh how ethical it is to apply
harm to
to a virtual laboratory so especially
when you associate yourself
uh with them right like it's different
the experiment that i was showing on the
milgram or beating school authority
uh where we you know you were
electrocuting this
other avatar of course there are ethical
issues there because you shouldn't be
electrocuting people and there is
a um an issue i think in both cases
with you becoming accustomed to
creating that that type of
[Music]
normal interaction is something that
shouldn't be normal like producing harm
and the the issue with harm and pain
perception i need to explore
across perception and there are full
labs dedicated just to this
uh is that for humans pain is is a very
important mechanism to react in in the
environment
right like if you burn your hand you
move super fast and
and there are so many responses that
happen attached to it
i've been trying to move away from harm
um
and i remember when i was a phd student
with mel slater we had a whole seminar
on whether we could find ways where we
don't need to harm people anymore inside
the
vr to to demonstrate that people react
right i think it's a bit of a a
problematic thing
in general um that it's hard to
demonstrate some things like
it's hard to demonstrate your embodiment
until you break embodiment
or you know like some of these things
it's it's hard to
to find ways to do it and that's why i
think questioners that
have very good dynamic range or um
can be helpful uh in that sense and and
and that's why i think things like
interoception or
other type of tasks that can help you
distinguish whether people are reacting
or not to something
could be very interesting to to reduce
the need for
harm let me go into some other questions
um yeah the thing that
is very interesting right like this
diversity
across different participants even when
presented to the exact same experiment
they will respond differently so
sometimes you don't even need to have
different conditions to find
different responses to the experiment
and what you will find is that the
people who were embodied had a very
different experience and the people who
were not embodied and there was a
question here
about findings differing between people
who were dancers athletes yogis higher
embodied awareness
and people who have less bodily
awareness and and this is super clear
it's the same that
um people who have some sort of
dysphoria
or you know whatever pathological
condition could be
that is affecting your body image your
body perception
even tetraplegias their experiments
don't
you know if you don't feel this is your
body anymore because
uh you you have no sensory input from
pilot of your body because you're on a
paraplegia um
that completely changes how you can
perceive uh this is your body
and in fact many of the original
experiments from body perception
come from that type of you know amputees
or
so it really really changes how people
uh will respond and and i think
that is important to keep in mind um
that you know different people will
react differently
and i think that is one of the reasons
why
we need to think of how we're gonna
represent people in different ways
so i want to move forward
there was some other questions
um
so yeah there are some questions about
the
integrated stimulus right um
whether you can consciously train your
reactions to
a stimuli uh in like intensifying an
illusion
or etc so one thing that i've
experienced
myself is the more i enter vr
the more i'm like wow by vr right like
it's been many years already but when i
find myself into a really nice avatar
um it feels like
it it's even easier for me to switch to
say oh this is me now
you know you become a custom you have
more flexibility
and i i feel this has happened to me it
could happen to other people but
we definitely don't have a lot of
longitudinal studies
and and we will
have them soon right a lot of people are
using technologies
like this um i think training
is a very important thing a lot of
people are looking for example at racial
bias how can you reduce it
can you expose yourself to particular
trainings there's been some amazing work
on
domestic violence rehabilitation by for
example mabi
sanchez bibis a professor back in europe
and the the work there
uh is that you can prepare particular
setups that will expose a person and
then try to get the right reactions
so one of the challenge here is that
maybe
uh the the the exposure that you're
producing
it is not generating the correct
reaction right like it's not reducing
bias
um so you need to have
test this very well before you can
really use this training for real but
like in general in life the more you are
training into something
then the more um you'll get better at it
or you know improve in in a particular
way
uh there are all sorts of trainings
right like phobias
fear of speaking publicly fears you know
all these things that can be trained
um so avatars ai or or
actors so i think we're at the verge
there
uh we're moving into a point in which
with tools like the move blocks you
could create a very good motion banking
and then use that to trigger ai avatars
and if you look at the milgram
experiment that we did
it's kind of in the middle right like
you use an actor
to to have these sort of
motions that you can trigger and then
you use some sort of logic system to to
go trigger them as
you progress i think that's going to be
an area that will explore more and i
think actually avatar ai
is going to be very important because uh
things like simulations in ai like
um you want to train a self-driving car
uh do you want to train you know
many things that require there will be
humans there
and i think having synthetic data that
you can generate
can change completely how we are
tackling these type of problems
first you can reduce bias on ai
using this type of techniques and second
you you keep the privacy of people right
you you don't have to use data sets of
real people if you can simulate them but
of course we we need to get better at
simulating
the roles of embodying mechanical robots
so yeah as we say
right you can embody an avatar and an
avatar can also be a robot i think i
show an example there
there there is a this idea of
um failure operation scenarios
which i think can can work
very nicely with the whole theory of
embodiment and there are many things we
can learn
from from what we are learning with the
avatars trying avatars
uh to to then transfer to robot in fact
there is another resource that you might
enjoy which is
psy it's a psi
um developed by dan bohus and
sean anders also here at msr
and we're trying to converge both right
this is a tool that
allows for multi-modal input to trigger
different outputs and they've been using
robots and i'm like
you know it's so much easier to work
with an avatar that doesn't run out of
battery
so i think many things in the mechanical
engineering
can be simulated with avatars before you
move into robots
and i think also the comparison could be
very nice
let me check some more questions we
still have some more time
um ar yeah i i have a couple of
questions around they are
yeah i talk very much about br in this
seminar
but i think most of the learnings apply
also to ar and i think
we're converging a little bit right like
ar and vr are currently very different
devices
but they might converge and they we
might end up having just
one single device and more of this
blended reality and you'll decide how
much blended do you want
and and i think many learnings can
transfer
but particularly vr has its ability to
block
your site of your own body so you can
experience much more these self
bodily illusions apart from all the
other aspects of interacting with other
avatars which are completely
transferable from vr to ar
so your own models
here about rocketbox let's move into the
libraries
i think the use of libraries as i say if
you're working on things there
this is open source now it's mit license
so it's no longer
only for academic and research use we
have a
widen the license floor open source
use it for whatever you want and
um we hope also this will help
academic uh universities to
you know spin off things out of it um
regarding the use of the models you can
use these models
and do all sort of things to them for
example things that i've done
uh use alpha blending on the uh textures
to remove an arm
and then use the arm of a different
avatar or you know like
that way you can actually have a face of
an avatar
on the body of another avatar you can
play with all these things
um regarding the move box
as i say move box is mainly these three
projects
one is for embodiment one is um a
capture studio sort of
and then the third one
is this sort of simple parts are
from the max planck a you can export
simple and simple can be imported to the
move box right um so
you know with these three tools i think
you can do a lot of things but if if you
want to do more things like for example
facial animation like here they're
saying
you can use the really in uh for the
face
um that it's already rigged and
and use it for for animating the face
currently we don't have a face animation
a head box
we're thinking about building it and
we're working on it
and if you know if someone is working on
that to
let us know another thing that we're
doing
with the rocket box is um
we're now creating uh importers for
unreal we're working also with blender
if anyone is working on these things
and has solved some of the issues also
reach out
okay so
some of the questions here i think we're
almost
done with time
uh there are some problems that um
are asked also on perception effects
of uh you know robert honey lucian
robert honey lucian
has been so explored there are so many
experiments about it
things that have to do with even
controlling the rubber hand illusion
this effect that
uh it and it's a rubber hand right it's
not even an avatar that you can actually
have control
of it so i do think that the literature
in the robert han illusion
um can teach us a lot about avatars
but i also would love to see the
people and working on rubber hunt to
stop working on rubber hands and start
using avatars i feel like you can do so
many more things
and i think we're past this moment in
which
you know you you would say you were
working on vr and you wouldn't get into
pnis
or or uh nature or i think that
were past this time and everybody agrees
that
vr can perfectly uh
you know uh be used for
for a body experiences
um regarding the rocket box can they be
put into mozilla hubs
lastly uh i think there are people
working on this already
i'm looking forward to starting a better
community to
to ask questions and and share
a work around the rocket box avatars
currently the only way i'm interacting
is with people
asking questions through the github
which are generally more like
issues they're having like errors they
found
you know this texture doesn't work well
or something like that
um but i yeah i think i we should put up
uh some sort of channel for further
uh work on the on the microsoft rocket
box avatars
so yeah the the the things are broadcast
right the audiences and this
will be the last question uh
so getting
characters with sign language
interpretations and in general
all this idea that we are not good
enough
right and we're not good enough on
on some of the animations yet but i
think we need more people to be working
on that
and we need more resources
like the avatars but i feel like a lot
of people now
are creating tools and one of the
aims for example with the max planck
people
to to have their sample
inside the rocket box avatars is this
idea that we can use computer vision
improvements and transfer them to these
avatars in a in a easy way
with different types of um
parsers so i think we're gonna see
breakthroughs on these things that were
not good enough
and very soon they will be good enough
right for broadcast for
training ai for really interacting with
an agent
like psy or you know substituting a
robot
so um the latest version of the
embodiment questionnaire will be
available soon
and i think
we are done with the questions i think
right
i will thank you everyone for attending
today
i i really uh appreciate your
participation it was great to see
people in the audience from all over the
world
i know there are different time zones
and it's kind of crazy to follow this
type of
webinars these days but also we can
all join it's it's becoming very
democratic
in that way very much easier to to see
things and go to places this way
so i i i look forward to
to see how you guys build on top of the
rocket box avatars to be
you build on on the theories that we've
been proposing very recently the
follower effect the uncanny valley
of haptics how does the all these things
apply to to vr uh and avatars
and ar and also
you know what all the work on the
embodiment questioner i think it's great
that we have standardized ways to do
this
and you know have a great day thank you
very much